off in the distance lightning strikes
leaving a beautiful flash of light
and then it's gone if you blinked or
looked away you would have missed it and
never known it happened
that is until the thunder rolls in
we all know that sound is slower than
light and that's what creates the
phenomenon of thunder lagging behind
lightning
and if you want to figure out exactly
how far away a lightning strike is
there's a simple trick to use all you
got to do is count the seconds between
the flash and the bang
and for every five seconds that you
count as a mile to the distance
um actually it'd be 4.7 seconds if the
air is already 70 degrees fahrenheit and
there's no humidity and also which means
that sound travels at about 760 miles
per hour
but what does that look like by simply
putting a camera on a car
and then speeding up the footage in post
i can show you exactly what that looks
like
if you were a sound wave traveling
through the air this would be your view
the speed of sound is really fast
however it's actually not that much
faster than flying in a commercial
airline so going the speed of sound
wouldn't really reduce your flight times
all that much the concord for instance
used to fly from new york to london at
twice the speed of sound and yet it
still took three and a half hours to
complete that journey
[Music]
wait hold up though what we're seeing is
the speed of sound through air
but what about the speed of sound
through other things as it turns out the
speed of sound is actually very
different depending on what the medium
is that the sound is traveling through
the primary thing that does determine
the speed of sound through a medium is
the stiffness of the material
the more rigid the object the faster
sound will travel through it
well technically density plays a factor
too the more dense the object the slower
the sound
that is technically correct but it
doesn't play nearly as large of a role
in determining the speed
as the rigidity of the medium let's take
water for example
yeah it's all sloshy and wet but it's
still way more rigid than air
and that's because you can't swim
through the air
duh the speed of sound through water is
over 3 300 miles per hour
in fact it's one and a half times faster
than the sr-71 blackbird
a spy plane famous for being able to hit
mach 3. that's
that is fast man the thing about water
is that it is incompressible meaning
that you can't squeeze it into a smaller
space the same way you can with air
and that's partly what helps sound waves
travel so much faster through water than
through air so it makes sense that sound
gets progressively faster as you move
from air to liquid to solid
right so let's compare that to steel
steel is obviously way more stiff than
water because it's a
solid and a pretty hard solid at that
the speed of sound through steel is over
000 miles per hour which is 17 times
faster than through air
and what's cool about that is if you're
on some train tracks and an explosion
goes off a mile away
you'll hear it twice first you'll see
the explosion but then you'll hear it
through the steel only a quarter second
afterwards that's really fast because
through air it would take five seconds
um 4.7 now imagine that these tracks are
made out of rubber and you wanted to
hear that same explosion a mile away
well you'll be sitting here waiting
about 26 seconds because rubber is one
of the slowest mediums through which
sound can travel
it is five times slower through rubber
than it is through
air the speed of sound through rubber is
135 miles per hour and that is
so slow i might even be able to reach it
in my car
here we go
oh yeah
the scary part is i can't really see
what's ahead of me
perpetual movement 90
all right 100.
20.
[Music]
we got the shot we just went 135 miles
an hour
we just went mach 1 through rubber
but let's imagine one of the fastest
mediums diamond which is one of the
hardest materials in existence thanks to
its incredibly rigid carbon structure
and that allows for it to transmit
sounds absurdly fast we're talking
26 000 miles per hour which is 33 times
faster than through air
but also more importantly that is faster
than earth's escape velocity
that means that if you were going that
fast you would leave the earth's gravity
well and not
come back because that's as fast as
rockets go when they visit other planets
yeah that's what escape velocity is now
get out of my video
now before i end this video i really
wanted to compare each of these
materials against each other to really
show you just the vast
range of speeds different materials can
cause the speed of sound to be
at the bottom of the pack we have rubber
here obviously rubber is faster than you
would normally drive in a car but it's
still going to be super slow compared to
any of the others in this category so
let's just move
on this is air this is something we're a
little bit more used to so every five
seconds of footage you see here i'm
going a mile
down the road so what you are actually
seeing right now is the speed of sound
for these shots what i did was i drove
exactly 55 miles per hour i had my
cruise control on and i went that fast
for about eight miles and then i was
able to speed that up to really
demonstrate exactly how fast the speed
of sound
is water is where we start really
ramping things up it's over four times
faster than through air
so this clip will be four times shorter
steel though this is where we get fast
and it's done and finally
diamond which is so absurdly fast that
it goes through eight miles like this
and just like that it was over 1.1
seconds
that's how long it takes the speed of
sound to go eight miles
through diamond 1.1 seconds compared to
three and a half minutes through rubber
that is just mind-boggling and we've
made it to the end of the video thank
you so much for sticking with me here i
had a really good time exploring the
different speeds that sound can go
if you thought this was interesting i'd
really appreciate it if you shared it
with your friends maybe hit that like
button
smash it as they say here's a sneak peek
for the next video you know those little
videos that show the different sizes of
stars throughout the galaxy well
i think there's a better way to do it
stay tuned and subscribe to find out